welcome back everybody we are dancing to
live your life by nick cordero and it
happens to be
our next guest's favorite song we
can't wait for him to join in on the
mother's day fun making his
television debut please welcome amanda
and nick's son the very adorable elvis
[Applause]
[Music]
cordeiro
oh my goodness oh
you guys i can't believe he actually
just did that
he's like right to the trash yeah he
went straight to his gift you know i was
gonna do the niceties but clearly elvis
you found your gift from us it's a trash
truck
[Applause]
that's it that's right oh my gosh
how funny this is adorable hi elvis
can you say hi oh my god
so uh ellis and amanda there is a very
good friend of the talk who didn't want
to be left out of the occasion
uh so she got some of her buddies and
there's a special video message for you
elvis look look at the camera let's take
a look
amanda i'm here at sesame street and i
know you don't need any advice for me on
how to be a good mom
i see how great you are with elvis and
how much you love him
i can only tell you this it only gets
better as much as you love this stage
with elvis
it only gets better doesn't it guys yeah
yeah
we just we love you amanda we just want
you to know we are cheering
you on and we wish you a happy mother's
day and we can't wait for you and elvis
to come to sesame street
well elvis we have something else for
you we know how much you like to stay in
style
even at bedtime so go ahead and open the
box
look at him he's just recycling
he's very good about recycling
[Applause]
[Applause]
very hot this season
all right amanda since we're celebrating
mother's day today
we of course have something special for
you too oh my gosh you guys are so sweet
yeah oh my gosh is this an adult one
are you kidding me oh my gosh
what iconic i know what our plans are
this weekend
thanks guys
[Music]
you